Привіт. Я – Петро
Чорноморець, вчитель біології,
співавтор демократичної школи «Майбутні».
І наші друзі, ми зараз з Вами будемо
працювати, ну і одразу таке питання:
– Знаєте тролей-проблем,
або проблема поїзда?
– Ні. – Така моральна дилема класична?
– Ну, коли перевести стрілку і
вбити одного, чи декількох людей?
– Так-так. Тобто,
наприклад, у нас є рейки…
– А, я чула про неї, декілька людей.
– Тобто у нас є рейки, ми говоримо про те,
що тут на рейках є,
наприклад, четверо людей. – Угу.
– Тут є стрілка, яка переводить
рейки, і тут у нас одна людина.
І Ви стоїте ось тут, і Ви не встигаєте
підбігти когось там якось відв’язати.
Ви можете тільки взяти, ось тут
важіль перемкнути, поїзд має їхати сюди,
Ви можете перемкнути важіль, щоб він
поїхав сюди, можете не перемикати важіль.
– Угу.
– Як Ви для себе вирішите цю дилему?
– Ой, це складно, але я колись чула,
що людська реакція залежить від того,
хто на рейках стоїть, якщо
це якась близька тобі людина...
– А ти особисто? Давай от так поки що.
– Я особисто? Ну…
– Що б ти робила?
– Я би кричала всім: «Тікайте!».
Голосно. На весь голос.
– Ну, вони прив’язані. Та нічого
реально з ними не можеш зробити.
І ти тільки перемикаєш або не перемикаєш.
– Ну напевне теж залежить
від того, хто ці люди.
– Якщо просто незнайомі.
– Тоді один.
– Ти перемикаєш?
– Угу.
– Тарас?
– Ну, все залежить від світогляду людини.
– Ти конкретно, у тебе є тут четверо,
тут один.
– Отже, а який у Вас світогляд?
– Ну звичайно, краще нехай
виживуть четверо, ніж виживе один.
– Тобто ти скоріш за все перемкнеш?
– Ну, якщо у мене лише ці ввідні
дані, то, звичайно, я перемикаю.
Якщо вони всі рівнозначні,
тобто це у мене немає
ніякої персональної
прив’язаності, перемикаю,
загине один – четверо
виживуть, як мінімум,
вони мають більше шансів,
не знаю, поширити популяцію.
– Якщо там не тільки чоловік.
– Ага, окей. А якщо тут дитина?
– От якщо тут дитина, починається
морально-етична площина
і починаються внутрішні
переживання, знову ж таки, я батько.
– Угу.
– Так.
– І вся ця історія, тобто тут
можна дискутувати дуже довго.
– Окей, і як Ви приймаєте
це рішення? Звідки вони?
– Напевно, виходячи із
якогось життєвого досвіду,
якихось ситуацій, які ти пережив.
– Мені здається еволюційна штука,
ми як живі організми, як істоти,
так, ми заряджені на
розмноження і на виживання.
Якщо говорити з позиції виживання,
то четверо дають більше шансів
вижити моїй популяції, ніж один.
– Тобто для тебе це інстинктивне рішення?
– Скоріше всього, це так само
як рішення, коли тоне родина,
і батько може врятувати
або маму, або дитину,
то здебільшого рятують маму, чому?
Тому що є репродуктивна історія,
мама може продовжити рід далі.
– Але дивись, але важливо, у тебе
логічні побудови чи інстинкт тут домінує?
– Ти знаєш, я думаю, що в тій
ситуації, якби ми стояли на рельсах,
що це не було б логічним мисленням.
Що це було б емоційне рішення прийняте,
тому що якби дитина
кричала: «Врятуй мене!»,
а четверо дорослих стояли спокійно,
то я реагувала би на якийсь збудник.
Тобто це залежало би від
ситуації, яка навколо мене.
– Тобто і у Тараса, і у Олі, да, це
було би точно інстинктивне рішення.
Тут взагалі можливе
не інстинктивне рішення?
– Я думаю, що це емоційне було
б рішення. Інстинктивно-емоційне.
– Еволюційна абсолютно
історія. Виживання. Інстинктивне.
– Просто це тут дуже важлива
штука, тому що от ми можемо думати,
що ми тут на рівні мозку
щось собі придумали,
і вирішуємо раціонально,
кого рятувати, кого ні.
– Ні, це було б нераціональне,
ірраціональне рішення, але воно б було...
– Ситуативне. – А в житті у Вас
взагалі бувають раціональні рішення?
– Звичайно. Ми так думаємо, що
воно раціональне. – А можеш приклад?
– Ну, наприклад, коли в мене є там
двісті гривень в магазині, так? – Так.
– І я починаю вираховувати,
що я можу придбати
і раціонально вибираю якісь
найоптимальніші варіанти
для того, щоб втиснутися
там в цю суму. Ну, не знаю.
– А навіщо ти взагалі купуєш? –
Ну, в залежності, в якому я магазині.
– Ну, все одно, в будь-якому магазині.
– Маючи якусь потребу. –
Тобто все одно інстинкт в основі.
– Угу.
– Ну, так.
– Ну, просто це важлива штука.
Дивіться, якщо ми читаємо підручник,
там просто сухо розписано
рефлекси, інстинкти, все таке.
Але якщо ми подумаємо насправді,
то виходить так, що розділити,
наприклад, раціональне,
те, що ми придумали, від
інстинктивного, по суті, неможливо.
Тобто без інстинкту ми взагалі
не можемо прийняти рішення.
Ми можемо думати, але не
можемо прийняти рішення.
В основі будь-якого
рішення лежить інстинкт.
І це, мені здається, дуже
важливо для розуміння інстинктів,
тому що коли ми читаємо у підручнику,
то взагалі не зрозуміло, що це таке.
Ми там бачимо тоді для
себе якісь дуже прості штуки:
інстинкт самозбереження –
окей. А все інше – це я розумом,
а насправді виходить так, що у нас
інстинкти управляють тим, як ми думаємо.
– Угу. А поясни мені, де в цій
історії емоції знаходяться. – А де?
– Якщо інстинкти – це набуті
якісь речі, які сталися з нами
в результаті еволюції, а
рефлекторно… А логічне мислення?
– Зараз, а давай рефлекс,
просто теж момент.
Тобто виходить, ми на минулому
уроці розібрали, як працюють рефлекси.
Виходить, що інстинкт – це
по суті складний рефлекс,
або складний комплекс рефлексів. Так?
Тому просто, щоб всім було
зрозуміло. Окей, тобто у нас є інстинкти.
– Інстинкти є, так, і логічне
мислення. – Ну так. Раціональне.
– Раціональне – сухе, а це
той самий мозок, який мислить,
який складається з тих самих
нейронів, тобто це та сама каша, тільки…
– Це та сама коробочка, тобто і ми
повертаємось до нашої коробочки,
яка якимось чином там щось
сприймає, сюди приходить інформація,
і тут якось вона діє. І виходить
так, що тут є якісь структури,
у яких щось записано на рівні генетичному
– це у нас будуть інстинкти, так?
А у нас є структура, а саме
конкретно кора великих півкуль,
в першу чергу, лобна кора – це
ті структури, якими ми думаємо.
– Мислять.
– Так, а де тут емоції?
– Передає, ну… – А давайте
так, ми взагалі знаємо.
– Передає те, що на виході ми
робимо? – Емоції ось тут? – Так.
– Тоді давайте розділимо, є різні просто
типології, я пропоную типологію таку:
почуття – це те, що всередині,
емоції – те, що ми виражаємо.
– Те, що ми проявляємо. – Окей,
тоді тут у нас буде поведінка. – Так.
– І ця поведінка буде забарвлена
емоціями. Так? – Так. А почуття це?
– А нас цікавить де почуття. –
Всередині, напевно, у коробочці.
– А як вони співвідносяться із
інстинктами, у нас тут є багато,
та і з лобною корою, якою ми
думаємо. Тут я напишу «кора».
– Це досвід якийсь, наприклад,
так? – Почуття – це досвід?
– Покладений на … Ні. Я не знаю.
– А ми знаємо свої інстинкти
взагалі? От Ви знаєте свої інстинкти?
– А... – Один точно знаю. – Який?
– Давай так. Давай,
якщо ми беремо завдання,
що ми всі запрограмовані
егоїстично на отримання чогось.
Ми всі поглинаємо: світло,
їжу – тобто всі наші наміри,
вони є з розрахунку заради себе, завжди.
Ми запрограмовані так, як автомат
з газводою, в який кидають гроші,
і з нього не може нічого
вивалитися окрім банки з газводою.
Так само і ми запрограмовані
так, не знаю, природою, еволюцією,
як завгодно, що ми все поглинаємо
і все робимо з наміром заради себе.
– Я думаю, що сюди ми
сильно копати не будемо.
– Так, я просто до чого
хочу перейти… – Так-так.
– При тому нам дана
ілюзорна свобода вибору,
коли ми під час акту розумової
активності робимо якусь дію і думаємо,
що це наш є вільний вибір,
хоча ми запрограмовані,
у нас інстинкти, у нас рефлекси.
Тобто ми, по суті, машина, яка завжди
робить так, як вона запрограмована.
Тільки чомусь їй дали змогу
розуміти, ніби в неї є вибір:
між тими штанами чи тими, між,
не знаю, тою гречкою, чи, чи, чи…
– Тобто ти машина? – І от в
тому до чого я кажу про почуття,
що в момент, коли я нібито
роблю свій вільний вибір,
мені здається саме в цей момент все
це окрашується якимись почуттями і…
– Окей. Давайте зараз розділимо ці
дві штуки. Тобто ідея…про те щоб…так…
– Філософію, релігію. – Тобто це
ми відхиляємо. – Релігії тут немає.
– Ідея про те, що ти
машина, одразу запитання:
які інстинкти змушують тебе співати?
– Бажання мої. – Окей. Навіщо
тоді цей інстинкт, що це за інстинкт?
– Інстинкт бути головним у стаді.
– Бажання, співати мене змушує
внутрішня якась жага до самовираження.
– Ну, або ще один момент: наприклад,
от беремо порівнюємо тролей-проблем,
де ми вибираємо кого
вбивати, кого не вбивати.
І беремо ситуацію позаминулого
року, у нас була така штука:
що поруч зі школою качка вивела
малих, і коли вони вилупились,
виходить так, що води там не має ніякої,
і цих малих одразу почали
зжирати ворони і коти.
От і виходить, коли ми це побачили (на
початку там, здається, їх було шестеро),
коли ми це побачили,
малих вже було четверо.
Ми цих малих легко впіймали,
але, ну що ми з ними будемо робити?
Без мами нічого, і от ми
намагаємось піймати цю качку
і, з одного боку, вона постійно літає
навколо нас і хоче до своїх малих,
з іншого боку, вона не дає її впіймати.
Тоді виходить так, що качка і
ти, ви нічим не відрізняєтесь.
– Абсолютно, абсолютно нічим.
Ми всі однаково запрограмовані,
тільки в кожного своя програма.
– Мені здається, що,
все-таки, принципова є різниця.
– В чому? – Ця різниця, давайте
трошки пізніше підійдемо.
– В свідомості. – Оп. –
Може, в свідомості. Так.
– Ага, дивіться: емоції, у качки немає
структур мозку, за які відповідають…
– Просто у качки немає ілюзії
вільного вибору. Вона реагує.
Це абсолютно реактивна історія,
а в людини є свідомість і оболонка
мозкова, в якій є ілюзія вільного вибору.
Мені здається, в цьому і є різниця
між свідомими і несвідомими істотами.
– Ну от, по суті… – Хоча
біологічно ми однакові.
– Біологічні передумови,
вони дійсно однакові, так?
Ну або не однакові, а дуже схожі.
Виходить так, що у нас є
якісь вроджені структури
і якісь вроджені програми поведінки,
і вони дійсно у нас, ну
не такі самі як у качки,
але схожі за своїм принципом,
але важливий є момент:
перше, що ми дійсно відрізняємось
принципово, тим що у нас є свідомість,
і ми до цього моменту ще зараз
підійдемо, як вона у нас працює.
І тут зараз момент, що
повертаємось до емоцій.
У качки тих структур мозку, які
відповідають за емоції, просто немає.
Тому що лімбічна система, яка відповідає
за емоції, з’явилась тільки у ссавців.
Чи можуть щось відчувати
птахи, я особисто не знаю,
тобто якщо подивитись
на ворону, наприклад. Так?
Тобто ворона, вона дуже круто мислить,
у неї вища нервова
діяльність досить складна,
але чи може вона відчувати емоції,
я не знаю. Структури у неї немає.
– Мені здається, що багато
тварин можуть відчувати страх.
– У них є стан стресу,
але немає почуття страху,
якщо ми говоримо про
тварин, які простіші за ссавців.
Тобто, наприклад, якась ящірка, у
неї може стан близький до стресового,
але у неї не буде почуття страху.
– Колись я заганяла індичат,
індичка вискочила мені на плечі
і робила дірку у мене в голові.
Бабуся сказала, що вона
була просто налякана.
– Ну, це агресія. Є схожість
поведінки у птахів і ссавців…
Але у птахів немає тих структур мозку,
якими ми з Вами відчуваємо почуття.
Тому як там у них це
працює, ну просто складно.
А тим більше, що птахів менше в
цьому плані вивчають, ніж ссавців.
Але якщо ми говоримо про ссавців,
то у нас так окрема група структур,
яка відповідає, якраз до чого я питав чи
знаємо ми свої інстинкти, чи не знаємо.
Тому що насправді ми не дуже їх знаємо,
вони у нас лежать переважно
в давніх структурах мозку,
і вони прямого зв’язку із корою не мають.
Кора дізнається, що у нас якийсь
інстинкт зараз актуалізувався,
вона дізнається якраз завдяки тому,
що ми тут відчуваємо почуття якісь.
От нам чогось не вистачає,
і тоді структури лімбічної системи
починають сигналізувати корі,
що нам чогось не вистачає.
І це, зокрема, є таке поняття
як «пошукове занепокоєння».
От то є стан, коли
щось хочу, не знаю чого.
І тоді я біжу до холодильника, так
відчиняю, що мені зробити? Так? – Точно!
– От, але насправді чому так відбувається?
Тобто у мене пошукове
занепокоєння стосовно, наприклад,
ось цієї структури,
так? І цього інстинкту,
а воно сюди дає сигнал, а кора ще
не знає цього сигналу, і вона думає…
– Сюди – це куди? – У лімбічну
систему, так? – У лімбічну систему.
– Яка відповідає за почуття. А кора,
вона така не знає, що з цим робити
і думає: «Ага, ну раніше мені допомагало,
якщо ось цю потребу
задовольняти, треба пожерти просто».
Я біжу до холодильника і
намагаюсь ось це закрити ось цим.
Тобто почуття – це насправді
те, що дає нам якраз зрозуміти,
що нам насправді важливо, що
неважливо з точки зору якраз ось цих,
так, інстинктивних
програм, які в нас закладені.
– А де виникає істерика тоді?
Он там, в лімбічній системі?
– Реально там же, так, там.
Тобто, наприклад, амигдала –
це та структура, яка відповідає
за тривогу, за всякі такі штуки.
Вона буде активуватись в такому
випадку і може бути істеричний стан.
– Чули, дівчата? – Чим ми
принципово відрізняємося, все-таки,
від качечки і собачки
також? – Ти казав. Кажи.
– Свідомість. – А як вона працює?
– Або ні, давайте, давайте ще зробимо
крок назад. Це такі наші інстинкти.
Які в нас є ще інстинкти? Бо там у
підручнику перераховуюь 4 штуки:
розмноження, самозбереження,
дитина (піклування про потомство),
і ще там щось. Це все? От дивіться…
– Ми інстинктивно прагнемо до
гармонії. До задоволення своїх потреб.
– Ну, а потреби це ж
якраз і є, власне, інстинкти.
– Маса. Це біологічні потреби
і далі, коли ми соціалізуємося,
у нас з’являються соціальні
потреби. Ми ж не сидимо голими?
– Ага. – Правда? Тому що всі…
– Супер. Тобто у нас є група інстинктів,
які стосуються соціальної поведінки?
– Звичайно, ми ж соціальні
істоти. – Наприклад, штука така:
експеримент проводили
на мавпочках-капуцинах.
Там мавпочка виконує роботу за
огірочок. А потім починають робити так:
одній мавпочці платять виноградом,
а іншій продовжують платити огірок.
Як думаєте, що оця мавпа
буде робити, якій огірок платять?
– Якщо вона любить
огірок, продовжувати роботу.
– А вона дуже любить
виноград. – Буде забирати.
– Ні, вони у різних клітках. – Буде
хотіти виноград, або не їсти огірок.
– Якщо просто дають огірок, вона його
нормально їсть, але якщо вона бачить,
що іншій мавпі дають виноград,
вона огірок більше не бере.
Вона починає кидатись у дослідника.
Виходить так, що у мавпи вже закладені
якісь передумови для справедливості.
І це теж у нас серед потреб,
по суті, серед вроджених ну…
– Інстинктів. – Інстинктів,
так. Більш прості якісь штуки.
Наприклад, коли Ви гуляєте лісом,
правда важко не перегорнути камінчика?
Подивитись, що там під
ним? – Ну, напевне так.
– Є ж така штука! Хочеться
просто це зробити?
Або чому діти люблять
обдирати шпалери на стінах?
От бачать шпалери, одразу
хочеться отак потягнути.
І дорослим це теж подобається,
просто ми себе зупиняємо,
у нас там гальмування вмикається,
тому що ми знаємо, скільки це коштує.
Але початково хочеться
відірвати щось. – Пізнання?
– В даному випадку важко сказати що
це, це просто якась інстинктивна програма,
скоріш за все, вона із лісу, коли під
корою там смачні личинки лежали.
– Якась їжа. – Так. Або дуже
люблять малі діти клубитись у багнюці.
Ми цього не робимо, тому що в нас,
знову ж таки, вмикається гальмування.
Тому що нас навчили, що там
інфекція, або бруд, або ще щось,
але той самий інстинкт ми задовольняємо,
коли місимо глину, або тісто.
Тобто у нас багато таких штук і,
насправді, дуже важливий момент,
що коли ти читаєш підручник, там
інстинкти якось дуже сухо описані.
Просто подивись – все,
що тобі подобається робити,
все, що тобі хочеться робити – це все
твої інстинкти. І це важливо розуміти.
От, а далі тепер, все-таки, от сюди,
тобто чим відрізняються принципово
наша качечка, або собачка, від
людини? Свідомістю. Як вона працює?
Свідомість – це про що?
– Це про аналіз.
– Так… Тобто качка, яка з одного
боку хоче до своїх пташенят,
з іншого боку боїться
нас, вона не аналізує.
– Ну, я не думаю, що
аналізує так, як людина.
– Дійсно, в неї там просто як
відбувається у рамках цієї коробочки.
Я іншу коробочку намалюю.
У качки є тут дуже просто,
є якийсь відносно простий
інтегративний центр,
є один інстинкт, є інший інстинкт.
Один інстинкт – це врятувати себе,
інший інстинкт – врятувати
своїх пташенят. – Потомство.
– Так, ці інстинкти зараз
протирічать один одному,
інтегративний центр якось його обробляє,
кожен момент часу видає якусь поведінку.
Якось воно обробляється, але
в основному через домінування.
Де збудження більше, там
і буде. Тому виходить так,
що коли ми відходимо від пташенят,
то качка летить до пташенят,
ми підходимо до пташенят,
вона починає тікати.
Ми врешті-решт її загнали у
вузьку щілину між гаражами,
впіймали там і винесли їх всіх
разом на Труханів острів, на воду.
Але все одно у качки дійсно
досить просто іде ця дія.
А в чому принципова різниця у
людини? Вона аналізує. Як ми аналізуємо?
– Через досвід? – Окей,
досвід. – Набутий. Через..
– Дивіться, стосовно досвіду. Який у
Вас найперший спогад із дитинства?
От реально? От я, наприклад, пам’ятаю
як це про те, як я тікаю від індика.
Мені було три роки, індик був вищий
за мене, важив, мабуть, удвічі більше.
Він мене дуже лякав, і я боявся
вийти за хвіртку, тому що там індик.
От я дуже добре пам’ятаю того індика.
– А пам’ятаю, як я сиділа на
горщику і розглядала свої ноги.
– А скільки років тобі приблизно було?
– Напевне, два. Десь так. Я, до
речі, дуже рано себе пам’ятаю.
Я дивилася на пальці і
думала, чому вони такі смішні.
– Окей. – Я пам’ятаю з
дитячого садка. – Так, супер.
– Ми планували з Андрієм, з моїм
другом, втечу з дитячого садка.
– Супер. Оль, дивись, ти коли розглядала
пальці, ти вже розуміла, що це пальці?
– Ні, я дивилася і вивчала, що це.
Ну, мені було цікаво. І я розуміла…
– Тобто знала, що це нога, що це
пальці? – Це нога, що це пальчики.
– І це важливий момент.
По-перше, ми дійсно, скоріш за все,
пам’ятаємо і більш
давні речі із нашого життя.
Але у нашій свідомій пам’яті
лежить тільки те, що ми знаємо
на рівні слів та понять. Це
називається декларативна пам'ять,
і в декларативній пам’яті у
нас лежать слова та поняття.
Виходить так, що ми починаємо мислити,
у нас з’являється свідомість у той
момент, коли у нас з’являється мова.
– Коли ми починаємо розмовляти.
– Коли навколо нас розмовляють.
– Коли я як особистість на рівні
мови… – Коли я сам можу говорити.
– Коли мій мозок починає
розуміти, що таке взагалі слово.
– Я беру дитину на руки, і я
розмовляю з перших днів постійно.
– Він чує спочатку голос.
– Так, він чує, так, але свідомість –
це коли він вже сам починає говорити.
– Так, коли він починає ці
слова, для них з’являється смисл.
Тобто коли я розумію, що це дошка,
що у неї є ніжки, що вона білого кольору.
– Я розумію, чи я можу сказати?
– Ну, я розумію, і я можу сказати з
цієї точки зору практично одне і те саме.
– Ні, ну є дітки, які розуміють, в віці
там в двох с половиною, трьох, але…
– Це вже значить, що в
них є просто, що потрібно?
Свідомість, вона працює
через абстрактне мислення.
Абстрактне мислення – це слова.
Якщо я ці слова розумію
хоча б всередині в голові.
– Тому якщо ми говоримо,
наприклад, про людину,
яка не може розмовляти з
фізіологічних, наприклад, причин.
Вона все одно, якщо у
неї вже є слова і поняття,
то значить у неї свідомість також буде.
– Тобто виходить, що ця
дошка, вона із просто образу
для мене стає набором абстрактних понять.
Просто дошка, що це ніжки, що
це білий колір, що це чорний колір,
що це маркер – всі ці речі
стають поняттями для мене.
Я вже сприймаю світ не в вигляді
просто набору образів і відчуттів,
а з’являються абстрактні поняття. Це
називається друга сигнальна система.
Тобто у фізіології є перша
і друга сигнальна системи.
Перша сигнальна система – це сприйняття,
по суті, безпосередньо від органів чуттів.
Там можуть бути і емоції також,
але в першу чергу це набір образів.
Друга сигнальна система – це
коли у мене з’являється слова
і відповідно до слів з’являються
поняття, з’являються зв’язки між поняттями
і так далі. І якраз це і є наша
принципова відмінність від тварин.
Ми можемо говорити про те, що в
деяких тварин, яких навчили розмовляти,
які не просто імітують звуки, як
наприклад прості папужки. Так?
А якщо це, окей, назвемо дуже
розумними папугами. Наприклад,
папуга Жако може запам’ятати
близько 300 слів, розуміти смисл слів.
– У нього є свідомість? – І може
навчити інших папуг цим словам.
І ми можемо говорити, що
якісь зачатки свідомості у нього є.
– Добре, а собаки, які розуміють,
що ти до нього говориш?
– Ось тут починається
якраз дискусійна така тема.
В який момент ми говоримо, що у тварини
з’являються якісь зачатки свідомості.
Тобто в принципі, якщо
тварина впізнає себе у дзеркалі,
розуміє, що це саме я, а не просто
якась тварина.
Тобто є тварини, які прямо
розуміють, що це дзеркало.
Був навіть кльовий відос, там де
собі начіплюють обличчя котяче люди
і тримають ось тут свою тваринку, і
тваринка дивиться на екран і лякається.
Тому що вона розуміє, що це
я, тут наді мною має бути хазяїн,
а чомусь тут на екрані наді
мною не хазяїн, а якась собачка.
Це якраз про якісь зачатки
свідомості у тварини,
тому що вона розуміє, що на екрані саме я.
Але скоріш за все, оскільки там
ще нема другої сигнальної системи,
то говорити про повноцінну
свідомість ми не можемо.
Тобто, свідомість – це про те, що я
розумію себе як особистість серед інших
і я можу про це помислити
на рівні абстрактному.
– Тобто, друга сигнальна система
– це наша принципова відмінність.
І якраз коли з’являється
друга сигнальна система,
то виходить так, що дійсно
основою наших рішень
будуть інстинкти, але ми
обробляємо їх принципово інакше.
Тому що тут просто: де збудження
сильніше, там качечка і реагує.
У людини багато різних
збуджених структур мозку,
складно обробляються корою, а
кора і на основі попереднього досвіду,
і системи цінностей, і людської моралі
дає принципово іншого рівня рішення.
І в цьому наша відмінність.
З вами був Петро Чорноморець,
викладач біології, співавтор
демократичної школи «Майбутні».
До зустрічі на наступних уроках.
По-перше, це цікаво. І
вчитель розповідає цікаво.
І я намагався підтримувати так дискусію,
щоб більш широко розкрити ці поняття,
про які йшлося на конкретному уроці.
Чи любив я школу в
дитинстві? Здебільшого, ні.
От і саме тому мені так
важливо, щоб уроки були цікавими,
принаймні для сучасних дітей.
Я, як мама сина, якому
5 рочків, дуже радію,
що нарешті з’явиться такий
проєкт на телебаченні, в ютубі,
коли ти можеш дитині не
просто тільки включити мультик
і займатися своїми справами,
а дійсно разом з дитиною сісти і
пригадати щось корисне із навчання.